hey guys it is Thursday the nineteenth
of January my name is Jess and you're
watching games but knees messed up a new
title has been added to the Nintendo
switch launch lineup publisher Nicholas
has announced that the binding of isaac
after birth Plus will be available
alongside the console when it launches
on march three the game will be solved
both digitally and physically and will
contain rebirth after birth and after
birth plus for 40 bucks Nicole's founder
Tyrone Rodriguez has also teased that
the first few thousand copies may
include something special though he did
not share any other details Oh today new
Carlos also posted an image of the
switches you I on Twitter the image
which has since been deleted featured
icons for several games including The
Binding of Isaac afterbirth plus 1001
spikes and Cave Story next up Nintendo
has confirmed that there will be no new
development for the Wii year nintendo of
america president Reggie Fiza may told
polygon that the legend of zelda breath
of the wild could be the last first
party game coming to the console he said
from a first-party standpoint there's no
new development coming after the launch
of the legend of zelda breath of the
wild we really are at the end of the way
here he went on to say that wii u games
will continue to be sold at retail and
on the Nintendo eShop and that online
services for the system and
high-performing Nintendo games like
mario kart 8 and splatoon are staying up
for now finally psychological horror
game the town of light is coming to Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 following its
launch on PC last year Italian developer
lka has announced the town of light will
be coming to ps4 and xbox one sometime
soon though no specific date was given
the game inspired by true events at the
Volterra psychiatric asylum in Tuscany
will also get an improved pc version the
enhanced edition of the original will
offer new puzzles additional story
elements reworked voiceover dialogue
more interactive elements and a huge
graphical and UI overhaul that aims to
deliver a more polished and immersive
experience that's everything I have for
you today do leave me your thoughts on
today's stories and we'll be back with
more news
mar